and they'll take their swings off of
matt harvey making his 23rd start of the
year and he has completely turned around
his season after a very rough
first half of the season he has been the
best pitcher in baseball since the
all-star break
could be another one here hayes and
mullins on the run austin hayes will
make the catch
up to 498 for his career two home runs
shy joining the 500 home run club got a
one-two
through the hole on the right side
good piece of hitting by miguel cabrera
now 52 away from 3 000 from miguel
cabrera highway stay productive didn't
get the home run miggy get the hit
castro first pitch swinging on the
ground to mateo at second base and
harvey leaves him loaded
in a scoreless top of the first
tarek scuba 23rd appearance in his 21st
start of the season seven and ten on the
year
the one-two he struck him out
orioles go one two three sure was derek
skubal with a solid strong 12 pitches to
get through the top third of the
baltimore lineup jonathan scobe flew out
to deep left field his first time mom
this time he's going to find the alley a
little bit
it's a long single for jonathan scope
that was hit hard now here's miguel
cabrera
301
rips this one through the hole on the
left side two for two night for miguel
cabrera the hits keep piling on base is
loaded again
oh one to haas
a little jam shot to first base trey's
gonna come home with it and get the
force out there
three to two
to retire scope at the blade matt harvey
executes this perfectly two seamer i'm
talking about right on the knuckles of
eric costa the nice play by trey manson
he's already playing even with the bag
comes in
and a good stretch
bases loaded two outs for castro in the
third
got him up and away
bases loaded one out and harvey escapes
it longest hit streak in the majors
right now 17 for cedric mullins
this one to first base cabrera backs up
and mullins is safe wow
cabrera
probably could have just taken it
himself he hesitated
and scuba didn't get there in time
scuba makes a mistake and so does
cabrera cabrera not aggressive enough to
get back
cabrera right there had plenty of time
but he didn't get his feet working and
scuba i think thought that cabrera was
going to handle that by himself and he
probably should have but still as a
pitcher you have got to get there just
in case and scuba never makes it
and if you hesitate for an instant off
of cedric mullins i'm going to tell you
right now you're going to get beat to
the bag
here's miguel cabrera
one two
driven to deep left field
back goes hayes still going back he
leaps it's gone
499
one away from the magic number 500 for
miguel cabrera
[Applause]
listen to these orioles fans
they know they're watching history
miguel crosses home plate points to his
family
really tried to get it down in the way
that he hung it
got it 4.99
candelario muscles one the other way
that's a fair ball
hayes cuts it off candelario digs for
second he's in there
with a one-out double
[Applause]
out of the box all the way
two ounce
great time to do this right here you
want to get position scoring position
good slide
late
right to the base pop up
position
castro bunts to first base mancini
shovel pass to the blade and got him
another terrific play
by trey mancini at first to the orioles
cut down candelario at the dish
now nico goodroom
the 1-0
that's a fair ball down the first base
line and into the right field corner
haas will score
he's waving harold castro home
castro will score as well and nico
goodram has himself a two-run double
but he may have gotten hurt sliding into
second base
zach short is going to run for nico
goodroom
[Applause]
he stands in with one aboard and one out
three struck out swinging his last time
up drills one into the left field corner
that was a bullet grossman
to third base he will hold there
thanks
to the hustle from the left fielder
austin hayes and jonathan scope has a
double
to set the stage for miguel cabrera
[Applause]
the pitch
to right field on a line mckenna's got
it
that'll work for miguel cabrera a
sacrifice fly to drive home robbie
grossman four-nothing tigers
and he's walked
this one skips by severino
scope trots home five-nothing tigers
on the ground and
franco eating up on his first chance
reyes
wide turn
hayes wide throw mancini the pick on the
run got come
what a great play
made by trey mancini and this ball is
hit maybe as hard as any ball hit
tonight this is just a rocket line drive
and it chews up 103 off the bat and it
chews up michael franco austin hayes
lets this one go but well high but
mancini's backing up but how about this
throw
across the bodies he's running out
towards right feeling nice
two and one to sign time there is two
for three that ball was just a little
bit low
oh my goodness is this going to stay
fair down the line absolutely clobbered
gone
way gone
easy utah street power
[Applause]
homers for the third consecutive game
he'll gladly wear the home run belt
watch this just a fastball middle middle
he's sitting there posing on that one
the only question was would it stay fair
and it does lead off single mckenna two
out walk mullins hayes the tying run
two one to hayes
grounds it to third candelario wins the
race to the bag and the tigers beat the
orioles 5-2
cabrera with career home run number 499
soto earns the save and the tigers have
won this series
you